how did you learn how to direct
well um besides the technical part of
going to film school and learning the
traditional
coverage and how to how to that
the dynamics of a scene
i learned how to direct by being a
soccer referee
and it's because when i was a kid
i played soccer and then i started being
a soccer referee and i was
on the field and i was good at it
because you had to learn how to make
quick decisions once you blew your
whistle
the game stopped and when the game
stopped you had to talk you had to
say why the game stopped and when the
game stops you have to
make a decision as as to which direction
the game is going to go in
whether it's a kick whether it's a foul
whatever and you have to have a reason
behind it
and people have to understand your
reason for stopping the game
and as corny as that sounds that is
very similar to being on set and doing
and when you stop when you cut and you
have to go again
that that for some reason that dynamic
transition to being on set and learning
how to make quick decisions and have a
reason
for why i'm stopping and starting for me
that's what it was i'm sure no other
filmmaker on the place of the earth will
tell you
that's how they learned how to direct
but for me that's just where i
drew it from stopping and starting
having a reason being able to articulate
it
fast and have there be meaning behind it
that's it and also yeah the meaning so
not doubting yourself
where you're wavering and then right
because as a referee you're not always
going to make the right you're not
always going to make the right call
but if you make enough if you do it well
enough the game's going to continue to
go on
no matter what and if you get good at it
you're going to make the right call more
than
the wrong call that's how i view
filmmaking with directing you know
you're gonna
you're not gonna always give the an
actor the best note you're gonna give
them the wrong note but more times than
none i'm gonna give the correct note
and if not i can live with that but when
someone else comes into my territory
who doesn't have you know whether it's a
producer or another actor trying to
direct another actor i don't like that
you know
if i'm gonna make a mistake and i'm
gonna botch a scene
let it be on me and um you know
and a lot of people can't direct because
they can't they don't know how to make a
decision
and that applies probably to a lot of
people's daily lives you know what do
you want
they just they're uncomfortable making a
decision that's going to affect
a lot of people and i think some people
naturally have that skill and some
people don't it's just being a leader
you know you're either a leader or
you're you're not
and directors have to be leaders
how do you block out and this is going
to be a weird question external stimuli
because you know how there's like tons
of stuff coming at you maybe it's a a
crowd scene maybe you're just you have
like five minutes left
how are you blocking out all these
different other factors that are coming
at you
and making sure that that one laser
thing that you're looking at
is right um well i think
you just through practice i think that's
one that's a skill that you
acquire through doing it a lot i think
you have to do it a lot i think that's
how actors who work
a lot become good they become better
because they learn how to
focus and and and they learn how to put
themselves get themselves in the right
mind
my frame of mind you know their kid
could have just like
gotten bullied at school that morning
and now he's got to show up on set and
do something else you know they figure
out it's a skill
and i think a director develops that
skill too as far as
figuring out what the goal is seeing
every scene every moment has a goal
there's
there's a purpose and if you can figure
out okay
let's just figure out this purpose take
a deep breath
just you know we'll get there and uh
not get too worked up over it i guess
this is a weird question but are you an
extrovert
or an introvert i don't know because
sometimes i'm very
i mean i'm i'm a homebody i very i don't
go out a lot i don't
you know i don't go to parties i don't
go to bars i'm just very
i like my own company a lot of times
because i'm in my own head
um but in the right circumstance i like
to be around people you have to if
you're going to tell stories otherwise
you're just going to
you know also too to command the respect
of
people working around you so i think
it's
how do you get out of your own head for
others that are in the same situation
how do you
in those moments where you have to be on
you have to make those
split decisions and have authority and
tell people what to do
um how do you when when you're more like
apt to be reclusive
uh you just you fake it you have to i
mean
and that you asked in that point you are
doing a job and you're assuming
you're doing the role of a director hey
directing's hard being a filmmaker is
hard it's not all about being creative
and
making your movie it's about being a
leader being able to communicate
being able to tell people what to do
listen to what they want to do
collaboration and being a businessman
if you don't want the whole ball if you
don't want the whole the whole ball game
then you know don't do it it's not all
about just being creative and being in
your own head
you know same with acting actors actors
go through a tremendous amount
of inner like press stuff and and
playing
the game and meeting people and having
to fake it and
they do a ton of that it's not all about
being in a character and getting to be
creative
i'm playing and being on stage they got
to do all this
stuff and and and play the game
and and be a businessman and you know
so
you